hello my name is Kendra Godwin and I am
a 2016-2017 associate fellow at the
National Library of Medicine referred to
here in this presentation as NLM this
recording was created as part of my fall
project in partnership with the
exhibition program of the history of
medicine division I produce this to
serve as a guide for individuals who are
developing companion programming in
preparation for hosting the exhibit
confronting violence improving women's
lives while this is my primary audience
I hope this presentation inspires you
with ideas for whatever project you're
mounting in this video I will walk you
through four sections I will introduce
the traveling exhibit confronting
violence the reasoning behind companion
programming experiences and examples
from confronting violence hosting
institutions and three of my own
programming ideas for you confronting
violence is a traveling exhibit curated
by dr. Catherine Jacquet and produced by
NLM told through images and records it
explores the critical role that nurses
in the 20th century played in
identifying treating and preventing
domestic violence the traveling element
which we will be hosting at your
institution is comprised of six
freestanding banners seen here on this
slide
these panels simply and evocatively
communicate the themes of confronting
violence
in addition to this exhibit there is a
companion website with more information
a digital gallery and resources for
education and for their study that
include related resources at NLM this is
designed to support hosts as they
prepare for the promotion of the exhibit
and the planning of related activities
and programming the central question
that has driven the creation of this
recording is how can NLM better support
the efforts of the hosting institution
to reach and meet the needs of its
community members related questions also
include how might the community members
at are brought together by your
institution respond to confront a
violence what stories might you want to
tell and how best could nln resources be
introduced and integrated to further
learning and conversation confronting
violence covers an important topic and
can inspire meaningful thought and
collaboration at your institution an NLM
wants to assist in helping you engage
beyond just the traveling exhibit and
its promotional materials the companion
programming ideas I have developed and
will present here shortly are meant to
provide a comfortable starting point for
individuals to explore NLM databases and
other resources before beginning this
project I thought it was critical to
speak with institutions that have hosted
our hosting or will host confronting
violence in order to understand the
reasons for selecting the exhibit their
actual or anticipated experiences and
any supplementary activities or programs
that they had planned I sent out emails
to six individuals who were exhibit
contacts heard back from five and was
able to collect insight from for these
individuals are as follows
Aphrodite body comb Associate Director
for administration and operations was
hosting confronting violence at the time
of our communication from September to
November of 2016
Laurie Fennell reference and patron
Services librarian hosted from October
to December of 2015
Beverly Murphy assistant director of
communications and web content and
hospital nursing liaison for the Duke
Health System is scheduled to host from
May to June of 2017 in Judy Stribling
manage
of the my remand patient Resource Center
hosted from February to March of 2016
common themes emerge from their
responses reasons for hosting this
exhibit includes believing the topic to
be timely of personal interest important
or important but not given enough
exposure individuals also felt that it
was suited to or could complement their
Health Sciences programs they wrote that
the panels are informative appeals of
various groups across their campus and
that the theme can be used to make
connections across multiple campus units
there was also mention of foot traffic
and wanting something present in a
public space to engage visitors
individuals responded in a similar
fashion to questions regarding companion
activities or programming that they try
to compliment exhibits with their own
efforts but never possible be it a
display of items from special
collections or a creative visualization
of the number of individuals impacted by
violence daily one individual did note
that space timing and manpower can be
prohibitive to these endeavors
recommendations from all included
inviting guest speakers and scheduling
panels or lectures one involves a
student who shared personal experience
and another was a sexual assault nurse
examiner ideas for groups to invite
include those who deal with domestic
violence on a daily basis like law
enforcement psychologists and health
care providers there was also talk of
involving internal medicine health
services the nursing school and the
School of Social Work I also thought it
was important to understand the
community members of the hosting
institutions that responded starting
from their web sites I researched what
schools populations and organizations I
serve and what these services entail and
I imagined what their community member
needs might be and what programming they
might respond to that insight is also
included in my programming efforts I
want to
for a moment to the creative
visualization I mentioned a minute ago
I had the opportunity to visit the
Health Sciences and Human Services
library at the University of Maryland
Baltimore in December of 2016 and the
two photos on this slide are from that
tour aphrodite body comb and her
exhibits team developed a display using
colored paper to reflect the number of
women impacted by various violence
within the span of only one hour the
case is full as the second photo notes
that every nine seconds a woman in this
country is a victim of a violent crime
while the confronting violence exhibit
is no longer hosted there the display
remains centered info a the first thing
people see when they enter the library
the themes of confronting violence
continue to make a powerful impact as a
majority of the hosting institutions
interviewed for my project and within
the experience of the exhibition program
our Health Sciences libraries for higher
education this is where I set my focus
the target audiences are faculty and
students the public and community
organizations and I considered
partnerships and NLM resources with
their interests and needs in mind my
first companion programming idea
incorporates resources from the National
Information Center on health services
research and health care technology
known as Nick HSR into the education of
nursing students Nick HSR is an arm of
NLM and its mission is to improve the
collection storage analysis retrieval
and dissemination of health services
research within Nick HSR is the health
services research information central
portal or HSR I see and I'm specifically
interested in promoting the research
support that this portal provides HSR I
see has a page specifically on domestic
violence aims of providing information
on this topic to assist researchers
policymakers and practitioners I propose
you use this resource to engage with
faculty and students through the
development of a workshop or
supplemental data that lecture and
discussion for the classroom
you can access this resource by visiting
the education section of the confronting
balance website and clicking on related
resources in NLM under the health
services research resource site tab and
pass the introduction there will be a
bank of links click on a link below the
domestic violence HS our topic page
alternatively you can also enter from
the main NLM website click on Health
Services Research and public health
below research at NLM at the bottom
middle of the page then HS our
information central under collaborative
projects finally select domestic
violence under HS are topics once you
are on the domestic violence page you
will see that it is divided into
numerous sections these sections include
pre structured searches on domestic
violence within emmalin resources news
data tool statistics assessment tools
guidelines and publications education
and training meetings conferences and
webinars grants funding and fellowships
legislation and key organizations as
mentioned on the page the literature and
resources related to domestic violence
are growing but can be difficult to
locate the goal of health services
research and public health information
programs is to integrate resources into
research and practice and for health
services research specifically the goal
is one of studying access costs and
quality taken as a whole I can't think
of anything more critical for today's
students and your programming it can
connect them to this resource domestic
violence began to be treated as a
significant health issue when concerned
and diligent parties proved its severity
with statistics and reports my idea for
the workshop over day of supplementary
curriculum is to keep this focus on data
assessment and screening tools as
expressed on the page nursing students
also need excellent training a focus of
the page as well
buy-in fidus idea requires facilitation
and agreement amongst nursing school
staff various stakeholders at the
institution should be involved before
any planning is undertaken but once
there is support these same individuals
be used for promotion and outreach I
also propose you invite a visiting
counselor to instruct and moderate
discussion amongst the students the
material for these discussions will come
from watching the older videos available
on the confronting violence website
within the digital gallery and students
will engage with one another and inform
their future methods with an observance
of behavior and practice both then and
now my second companion programming idea
involves introducing the public to
personal stories of domestic abuse in a
way that will foster communication and
community and encourage the exploration
of information resources I propose that
you consider both the perspective of the
healthcare professional and the person
who experienced the violence
I suggest planning a reception for the
opening of the confronting violence
exhibit where the public can attend
explore exhibit themes share experiences
and educate themselves on resources
available people of all ages should be
encouraged to attend promotion can be
done through local libraries and
organizations that specialize in
domestic violence relief and services
and the event can be advertised on
institutional social media the ease into
stories reflect on the past and present
and tie directly to the exhibit invite
both retired and practicing local nurses
they can provide personal stories of
experience reach out through your
nursing liaison librarian if you have
one or leverage your institutional
network I recognize that this is a
difficult topic and then not everyone
feels comfortable experiencing it or
sharing in the same way provide a space
and time for the public to share their
experiences as well but include a
collective creative area where art and
collage can be worked on as a sort of
therapy and icebreaker amongst attendees
set aside a space where these art pieces
can be displayed afterwards alongside
this reception it is important to keep
the public informed not everyone knows
where to access information relating to
domestic violence for this reason I want
you to direct the public's attention to
the up-to-date credible and linked
information of MedlinePlus MedlinePlus
is NLM's consumer health information
service and it provides encyclopedic
pages on many health-related
topics collected from NLM and across
trusted health organizations and the
information is available in both English
and Spanish MEDLINE plus has a page on
domestic violence specifically access
this resource by visiting the main NLM
website and clicking on MEDLINE plus
under databases or visit medlineplus.gov
directly click on either of the two
health topics icons my upper left from
there you can either search
alphabetically by clicking on D and
scrolling to domestic violence or by
clicking on social family issues under
health and wellness and scrolling to
domestic violence once you're on the
page you will clearly see how its
components have been structured to
connect to this resource while at the
reception computers or tablets should be
provided to make this resource
accessible with staff on hand to assist
with the provided technology or 410 DS
require help accessing MEDLINE plus on
their personal mobile devices
additionally you may want to complement
the reception and the ensuing months of
hosting with a local display of items
from your own special collections or
archives my third companion programming
idea involves across organizational and
cross-disciplinary journal club domestic
violence is a topic that affects so many
different individuals and bridges across
and beyond the Health Sciences by
partnering with community organizations
in your area and involving different
schools departments or units each can
lend a different perspective and
expertise would engage in conversation
with others the academic and the
practical can meet here to explore the
impact of domestic violence and how best
to respond and care for those who
experience it the companion webpage to
vi confronting violence banner titled
and the work continues notes that
activists today have developed
innovative approaches to sharing
information and assisting in recovery
while the exhibit mostly examines
domestic violence as it relates to women
in general there is an increased focus
on the specific needs of teens immigrant
women women of color and the role of men
in stopping violence use these ideas as
a springboard and consider as well how
this issue affects men
trans and cisgender individuals
differently make your institution and
the traveling exhibit the focal point
for the first meeting at a place
together shift to an online forum if you
feel that will keep and encourage
participation use institutional social
media websites and organization and lays
on contacts to advertise when selecting
your journal Club readings leverage the
free and full-text journal articles on
domestic violence via PubMed Central or
PMC PMC is the digital counterpart to
NLM's print journal collection it is an
archives of scholarly biomedical and
life sciences articles that are free
full-text and publicly available online
you can access a selection of these
writings by visiting the education
section of the confronting violence
website and clicking on related
resources at NLM under the PubMed
Central resource side tab you will see
16 articles listed with links directly
to the item within PMC one example
article is titled barriers to screening
for domestic violence from the Journal
of general internal medicine this is a
curated list and a great place to start
but there are many more articles
available via PMC using mesh or generic
domestic violence search terms PMC for
search purposes can be accessed by
starting at the maine and alum website
and selecting PubMed MEDLINE and the
upper left under databases either select
PubMed Central under popular at the
bottom middle of the page or enter your
term into the search bar and then limit
your search by PMC PMC can also be
accessed from the Maine and alum website
by clicking on all NLM databases and
api's in the upper left
under databases and then scrolling to
PubMed Central PMC in a 2014 medical
library association oral history past
NLM director dr. Donald Lindberg noted
successes of the exhibition program he
found it striking that every traveling
exhibit is amplified and made unique
with the things that each hosting
institution is most proud of
in addition to the ideas I covered today
I invite you to think like Lindbergh as
you plan for hosting and look through
the items and partnerships that you are
most proud of consider highlighting
these alongside the confronting violence
exhibit and uses them as inspiration for
activities in programming this is what
will set you apart and lead to a
successful and engaging exhibition
before closing I want to thank all of
the individuals who responded to my call
for comments on confronting violence and
for my colleagues at NLM for their
support you were all instrumental in
guiding my development of this project
please reach out to Jiwon and I with
your thoughts constructive comments and
any programming success stories you care
to share thank you for listening